today we're covering pass by value
versus pass by reference in javascript
arguably a fundamental and critical
topic to understanding and programming
i'll be giving you a full understanding
of how this works we'll go into depth on
the differences between values and
references step through some examples
and we'll talk about why this is so
important to understand
and more importantly if you stick around
to the end what knowing this enables you
to do in the future
to understand paths by value and pass by
reference i feel it's important to
understand a bit about how memory works
at least roughly let's think of memory
as this long array of values
so let's just draw this as a big
rectangle and you've got billions and
billions of these slots that can fit a
single byte
which is 8 bits why 8 bits because this
is often the smallest addressable thing
in memory for most computers
back to the drawing okay so you've got
billions of bytes and you can imagine
this as basically like an array
which also means that each byte has an
address in other words
given an address you can look up a
specific byte in memory
so we're all good so far when you
allocate a new variable
what you're really doing is reserving a
space in memory somewhere
to store your variable and to refer back
to that bit of memory you have the
address
obviously different types of data
require more than a single byte
so when you allocate something you may
reserve a whole chunk of memory and of
course the address will simply be the
start of it
for example allocating a number in
javascript well
the number in javascript is a double
precision float which is 8 bytes
so if you want to allocate memory for a
number 64 bits
or in other words 8 bytes are reserved
and depending on the type
more or less memory may be involved if
you allocate a string
well in javascript every character in a
string is represented by a 16 bit number
or two bytes so when you allocate a
string the amount of memory needed is
directly related to how many characters
there are in the string
in other words the longer the string the
more memory it uses
so what does this have to do with pass
by value versus pass by reference
we're building that let's talk about how
calling functions works
you're obviously familiar with using
functions in javascript
it's pretty easy so let's say i have
this little function up here called
calculate stuff
and it takes two parameters x and y and
does some calculations inside and
returns a result
now it doesn't matter what this function
does what we're going to do is look at
how it actually works
underneath in other words in terms of
what the computer and memory is doing
how does calling a function work when
you do a function call there's just
a few key concepts that you want to take
away you may be looking at some code
that's running and then you go to call a
function
what happens when you call it is that
you package up all the arguments
somewhere
it could be in memory it could be in
registers it doesn't matter for the
purposes of this
explanation then you move execution of
the code to the function
the function unpacks the arguments the
code in the function executes
and it may be that you eventually return
from the function and continue from
where you left off
and here's where passed by value versus
pass by reference matters
there's two common strategies for
packaging up all those arguments for the
function
the first is pass by value so that what
can happen is that you have this little
package of arguments
and what you did was you copied the
actual values into it
in terms of memory like we saw before we
go and get the actual values and put
them in the package
and that brings us to the second way to
package up these arguments which is pass
by reference
meaning instead of passing the values we
pass the addresses of the values
that's great but what does this mean so
this is a subtle but
important difference and it has profound
implications which we'll explore now
let's do a real world example let's say
i have a document
i've written and someone asked for
access now i could of course just make a
copy
that's simple enough and obviously any
edits or changes they make to the
document
don't get reflected in the original this
would be passed by value
i made an independent copy and gave it
to them
but i also have the option of sharing
the actual document itself the one i'm
working on
in google docs i can go hit the share
button put the address of whoever i want
to share this with and voila
now they can access my dock now if i
edit the document
they see the changes and if they edit
the document i also see the changes
this is passed by reference i gave them
access to the same document i have
and now we can both access it how does
this work in javascript
so i know my first question would be
something like how do i choose which one
to use
in other languages like c plus you
explicitly choose depending on your
needs
so it's not unusual to be browsing code
that mixes pass by value and reference
all over the place in javascript you
don't it's chosen for you
they've made it simple and easy straight
from mozilla's docs
primitive parameters such as a number
are passed to functions by value
the value is passed to the function but
if the function changes the value of the
parameter
this change is not reflected globally or
in the calling function
if you pass an object i.e a
non-primitive value such as an array or
a user-defined object
as a parameter and the function changes
the object's properties
that change is visible outside the
function let's look at some easy
examples of this in action
i'm going to define this function up
here let's call it try to change stuff
and we'll leave the inside undefined for
now let's start with some primitive data
types
so we'll begin with let x equal five
then we can call try to change stuff
with x
and we'll add a console.log before and
after the function call
and what should happen here is that if x
is the same before and after
then x was passed by value and if it's
different before and after the function
call it means that
x was passed by reference because the
function was able to modify it
and the change was visible outside of
the function
so now we run it and it's exactly as we
expected no change before and after
and this will be the same for every
primitive type so if i make
x a string and i make some changes to
the function we should still expect
no change before and after so if we run
this we get exactly that the string
stays the same before and after
but if we use a non-primitive type let's
say that x is now an array
and of course we make some small changes
to the function so that it modifies the
array
and let's log the contents of the array
before and after the function
this should be passed by reference
meaning the changes from inside the
function
should be visible outside and once we
run it we see that x before and after
the function
the contents have changed and this of
course happens with the other
non-primitive types too
so let's change x to a dictionary and we
can define some default values in there
we'll also modify the function to modify
the dictionary a bit
changing one of the keys finally we run
this and it's clear that the contents of
x before and after the function have
changed
confirming this was passed by reference
and an interesting note is that
assignment works pretty much the same
way
for primitive types assignment is always
by value
we can quickly confirm this so let's
make x back into a primitive value
and instead of calling a function we'll
create a second variable
y and initialize it to equal to x then
on the next line
we'll just increment it by one and i'll
add some additional logging so that we
can see the value of y
as well and after we run it we see that
x is still one but y is two
and this happens with any primitive type
just like it did with functions
if i use a string the original string
isn't modified
since assignment follows the same
pattern as function arguments
when we create a non-primitive type like
an array so let
x equal an array and then we create a
second variable y
and set it equal to x and proceed to
modify y
so let's say add a couple elements or do
whatever we want it doesn't matter
then you log the value of x before and
after and voila
it's changed why understanding this
thoroughly is so important
there's a few reasons really the first
is pretty obvious understanding your
code thoroughly
not just on a superficial level will
help you build applications where the
behavior is clear
consistent and can be reasoned about
easily in other words it'll help you
build programs with fewer bugs
secondly the concept of past by value
versus past by reference is something
fundamental to many programming
languages
learning what's happening if only
roughly under the hood will help you
quickly and easily understand what's
happening
should you switch languages finally this
ties into what does this
enable you to do understanding concepts
like this
is critical for building towards
understanding more complex ideas like
data structures
i'd like to move on to more topics
especially data structures and their use
in games
but you really can't understand those to
a high degree without knowing basics
like how memory works
without at least a passing understanding
of memory you can only understand
something like a linked list at a
superficial level at best
these all require a solid basis and
fundamentals otherwise you're not
thoroughly understanding the subject
matter
anyway hope this was interesting and you
learned something see you next time
cheers